yuh mean Oh hasn't felt safe in Cologne
since New Year's Eve crowds in front of
the main train station put her on edge
she wanted to meet up with some friends
to ring in the new year when suddenly
she was encircled by a group of men
is your finger none had an agreed so
they began to grope me it started off
tame enough touching my behind then I
got worse uh as you want as a I got
really mad I felt hopeless I was in
shock it felt so foreign zaire fremd
espanish i know this sounds really weird
but it didn't feel like Germany that's
not history deutschland that night
scores of women were assaulted robbed
some even raped hundreds of incidents
were reported to the police prompting
protests in solidarity with the victims
once again the issue of migration was
pushed to the forefront the attackers
have been described as of Arab or North
African descent but some protesters
highlighted the danger of tarring all
asylum seekers with the same brush
azkaban three dimension there are so
many people who come here from a
different culture and managed to
integrate well ah but we do need a
tougher response to people who refuse to
accept our culture don't suppose watch
things on which means that same yawning
done in Germany for ten years and I
enjoy the sense of freedom here I
condemn what happened to women on New
Year's Eve that doesn't belong here
police believe organized gangs were
behind the robberies and sexual assaults
this angle to hear mine these people
aren't refugees in the real sense of the
word no they haven't fled war or
anything they're men who have come here
to support their families in North
Africa Chicago and Josh doutzen benzie
does New teton in Dame's if that were
the case that they were working to do
that legally or not it would be one
thing in a locked or under hello faddah
becoming part of organized crime here is
another and unfortunately the problem is
that it's the latter let so as the
slider go two sons of program the police
were unprepared for the horrors that
unfolded that night Islamic scholars say
what happened amounts to far more than a
clash of cultures lesbea Hamish is the
Arab Islamic world sexuality is highly
restricted sex before marriage is not
accepted and many young people can only
marry when they found a job is the men
who are supposed to support the family
and the come as a force in that you can
imagine that men are highly sexually
charged Dolph kelan's band as
frustration is reflected in the sexual
assaults boobalay happen every day in
the Arab Islamic world I take thee
opponents to Germany's open door
migration policy used the attacks in
Cologne as a platform to spread their
own messages far-right groups and
hooligans chanted anti-foreign slogans
Yamin o wants to see her attackers face
justice but she's also worried that
innocent refugees who fled war might
face discrimination
this was all of this dish does that such
an accomplished so clear that they came
from a completely different culture yet
Hoff intruder is thus I think they need
to learn what is okay in Germany and
Europe and what isn't in Dodge front and
ordained or wawa Berkeley she is on what
you can do and what you can't these
things didn't seem to be clear at all
welcome mr. cloud police officers were
overstretched and it's unlikely that all
of the attackers will be caught colognes
police chief has already had to go but
Germany sexual assault laws have also
come under criticism many believe that
attackers come off too lightly ya mean
Oh used to feel safe walking around
Cologne no she no longer does